Eric starts off this hour with us in
Salt Lake City hi Eric how are you I'm
doing great thanks for taking my call I
had a question about my mortgage I have
a a 30-year mortgage which I know you
recommend against now if you're
listening to you but I really get
interest rate at 3% which I guess is I
guess is good that's actually my
question so so my question is is that my
mortgage really isn't that much I paid
off about mmm 20 pounds and are at ten
ten thousand so it's just about a
hundred and thirty thousand mm-hmm
I have about fifteen thousand dollars
cash saved up besides my emergency fund
and I was and I was wondering if it'd be
better to switch to uh to refinance to a
different you know like a 15-year loan
so that way the more that we go towards
principle and try to pay the loan off
faster you know just financially I just
haven't taken the time to research the
numbers right
it's interesting mathematically if you
pay extra on a 30-year mortgage to where
the amount of your payment is the same
as it would have been on a 15-year
mortgage it pays off in exactly 15 years
yeah and so it's you would not refinance
to pay a thirty like a fifteen if you've
got an advantageous interest rate which
you do you've got a great interest rate
so no you would not refinance in other
words you would just pay extra now when
you're at baby step four which means
you're debt-free everything but the
house is that your case we do have my
wife's car which is about I think you
have about ten thousand on that buzzer
than that been completely debt-free
well you're not debt free then and you
should take that fifteen thousand and
pay that car off today yeah that's extra
above your emergency fund you said right
correct why are you sitting around on 15
gram the car payment uh just for
emergencies I mean watch you have an
emergency fund you told me yeah this
just for the odd stuff I don't know I
mean I guess just for security really
how about just financial laziness
would that work I'm fine with dog right
a check valve your car dude today okay
because you got the extra money to do
that now then we're going to be putting
15% of your income into retirement are
you doing that no okay you should adjust
your 401k oh and or by a Roth IRA coming
monthly out of your checking account
into good growth stock mutual funds to
the tune of 15% of your household income
and you may need that extra five after
you pay the ten thousand dollar car off
with the extra 15 you have laying around
- maybe fund your Roth IRA and get some
stuff started so let's let's reserve
that money for that then if you can find
extra in your budget while you're doing
that I would suggest you pay your thirty
like a fifteen rather than refinancing
it don't go to the expense or trouble to
refinance because you already have a
good interest rate mathematically on
that part of the equation do you see
what I'm saying yeah okay so if you just
get a financial calculator out and you
run the payment how long have you had
this mortgage only three years okay so
now you're at twenty eight years or
twenty seven dollars twenty seven years
yeah okay so if you want to pay it off
fifteen from today you would take your
current balance put in the interest rate
put in one hundred and eighty payments
which is fifteen years and it'll spit
out a payment that is the principal and
interest you would have to pay compare
that to your principal and interest now
and not counting taxes and insurance
just principal and interest and the
difference is what you need to pay extra
to paid off fifteen years from today if
you want to pay it off fifteen years
from when you started then you would not
use fifteen years from today you'd use
twelve years from today right yeah and
so then we would just put a one hundred
and forty four payments in twelve years
of payments and then we'd be ready to go
so either way you just put that in the
financial calculator and the answer to
your initial question in the call it do
I do I throw this fifteen thousand or to
our refinance the mortgage neither one
we're going to throw the fifteen at the
car and at getting your retirement going
being a hundred percent debt free then
you have an emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses in place and then
we're putting fifteen percent of your
income into retire
that's baby step four then as we can
find extra we're going to pay extra on
the house hopefully paid off faster than
12 or 15 a lot of people Eric doing our
stuff that really pay attention and lean
into it and are diligent are paying off
their homes in an average of seven years
that's an average so some are taking
longer some are taking shorter but
that's doing it pretty quickly they're
leaning on it and again that's just
rolling up your sleeves and saying I'm
not going to let money just lay around
doing nothing we're going to make all
the money that we have have a genuine
defined clear purpose and that's three
to six months of expenses for emergency
fund 15% going into retirement that's
every extra dollar going on the house
watching the budget we're making the
money behaved telling it what to do
jumping on every dollar calm get your
budget going for free all that kind of
stuff thanks for calling in - appreciate
you joining us
you